hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the ethics of ambiguity in section 2
simone de bevoir
examines and analyzes a number of
different
defective uses of human freedom
ways in which freedom denies itself and
not only denies itself or nullifies
itself but conceals
from the human being their own freedom
and responsibility
and the second of these is what she
calls the
serious person the person who
is you might say choosing the path
of the serious object and of seriousness
as a kind of comportment and as she
points out this
is an advance beyond the subhuman
although she will also point out
there's an affinity between these two
and when the
serious person loses their capacity to
be involved
in and make themselves central within
the realization of whatever it is
whatever value they've set up is the
serious thing they will often descend to
the level
of the sub person or in their their off
time they will
do that as well so there's there's a you
know
connection between the two of these the
serious person
can also lead into the third comportment
that she talks about namely that of the
nihilist
that we'll look at elsewhere so what
what is going
on with a serious person she talks about
the person submerging their freedom
into the context of the into the content
accepted from society so
there's uh some sort of as she's called
it before ready made
value something that other people
could provide that
reading that media that one's family
could give to one and then you say well
maybe i can rebel against this and say
that's not that important it has to be
placed into kind of a hierarchy
of values or you can say that's it
i have found what it is that i identify
with and she talks about
this person is a really great phrase
as suppressing themselves to the
advantage of the thing with a capital
t and the thing can be anything that you
want it to be
namely it can be any object that you
pick
she just says it has to be sanctified by
respect and it appears in the form of
again capital
c cause science philosophy
revolution etc she goes on a little bit
further and she says that
a frivolous lady of fashion can have
this mentality of the sirius
as well as an engineer there is the
serious here's what's definitional about
it
from the moment that freedom denies
itself to the advantage of
ends which one claims are absolute so
anything can become the series you could
be
a vegan and be caught up in the serious
this way you could be
a comic book collector the one who is
absolutely insistent on
the need to keep things within their
rappers and in mint condition
you know you could be collecting star
wars figurines that way and that could
become the the thing
fashion is a prime example people who
think that fashion
fundamentally matters uh you know and
that we
we have to obey its dictates that would
be the same thing people who are
involved in
really any sort of creative or artistic
uh domain in that way could be
the serious person as can somebody who
thinks that the military
is what is absolutely important people
who
buy into a political cause in an
unquestioning way
people in the present who echo all this
stuff about the founding fathers and
their intent
and you know liberty and and they do so
in a very abstract
manner i think they're arguably what
what de bevar would call the
serious person people do this as well
with their their religions
people do this with their anti-religion
people can do this
with all sorts of things exercise is
another great example
so actually diet too people who become
evangelists for
her diets so they suppress themselves
to the advantage of the thing and like
she says they subordinate their freedom
to values
that would be unconditioned now we need
to talk about this what does it mean
for them to be unconditioned it means
that nothing else
is qualifying them so if i say
for example that you know family is
what matters to me the most and that's
you know shows in the way in which i
carry out my life so i work very hard
to provide for my family i'm also not
one of those
well here's a great example of the
serious person the serious person could
be the person who works very very hard
because what matters to them is
providing a good home
and security to their family and they
ignore the fact that their kids
want engagement with them because
they're you know too tired
to to do so when they come home from
work or their spouse right
whatever it's going to be and and they
essentially work themselves out of
that value of family family is an
abstract value in that case
and the real needs of the family are
denied but i was thinking
instead what about somebody who's a
little bit more
you know substantively engaged with that
family
and they've like ticked off every single
box and then they get a kid who comes to
them
and says listen i was driving last night
and i think i killed somebody
and do you cover it up do you report it
do you investigate it do you deny it
the serious person you know
unconditioned values
would say family is what matters the
most forget other values like
living in a society for a value to be
conditioned
means that there is the call of other
values it has to be placed in relation
to other values
and so the serious person is somebody
who might have a hierarchy of values but
they're they're never
whatever's at the top is never going to
be questioned
or if it is that's when freedom comes in
and we have some some problems there
now she talks about this as a
repetition of the dynamic of childhood
that she discussed a little bit earlier
in this section she says it's easily
understood
why of all the attitudes which are not
genuine not authentic
this is the most widespread because
every person was first a child
after having lived under the eyes of the
gods that is the parents having been
given the promise of divinity
one does not readily accept becoming
simply a person with all the anxiety and
doubt what is to be done what is to
be believed and she says often the young
man who is not like the sub man first
rejected existence so that these
questions are not even raised
is frightened at having to answer them
after a more or less long crisis
he turns back to the world of his
parents and teachers or he adheres to
values
which are new but seem to him just as
sure so whether you rebel
whether you go back if you're just
taking these values as
you know for granted and setting them
them up as absolutes as unconditioned
you're
lapsing into this this seriousness but
this is doing so as an adult
not as a child so she says that there is
a dishonesty here
fundamental inauthenticity we could call
it what is it
part of it is that they have to
repeatedly renew this denial
of freedom she says this person chooses
to live in an infantile world
but to the child the values are really
given you see the child
has the repetition supplied by the
adults the adult supply
the ways in which things are done they
supply explanations
they supply examples often contradictory
ones granted
and the child has the adult giving them
or the adults giving them
how things ought to be
the adult well you know they can claim
well my leader does this or this writer
does this or
hears what my guru says but they're
really choosing it
because they are an adult so they have
to
and it and it can't be done once and for
all you can't find
you know let's say that wire was like
you're going to be your guru right
you can't read the book once and say all
right i've figured it out
once and for all now i never have to
think about this again
because you do have to think about it
you do have to reassert it that's the
nature
of human freedom and choice we are
unable to commit ourselves in such a way
that the one commitment
lasts for all time we have to recommit
ourselves
over and over again so
what's being denied here is the fact
that one is doing this
being concealed right she says the
serious person must mask the movement by
which
he gives these values to himself like
the person who while reading a love
letter pretends to forget
she has sent it to herself isn't that a
great
metaphor right there somebody would you
know
in this case you create a dummy email
account
and then email or even better a dating
site right you you get onto a dating
site
pretend to be somebody that you would be
attracted to
write yourself a nice little note send
it to your own profile
get it and then you have to say oh this
is so nice
somebody likes me i'll write something
back to them
and then you have to go back and pretend
that you're not that person anymore
it's very difficult to do that for
anyone who is authentic
because you know that you're you're
playing with yourself essentially right
so she goes on and she says um
that there's other things as well this
person is
freely establishing the value of the end
and making themselves a slave to that
end and they refuse to recognize
that they're doing this that is what
allows them to become the slave to the
end
because they don't they don't
acknowledge
that it's their own choice that makes
say the church
or the army or this politician
and and you know they're they're winning
the election or something like that
the prime uh value because they don't do
that they become enslaved to it
and they are enslaving themselves so
there's a
really strange dynamic but a common
dynamic
going on here she says he forgets that
every goal is at the same time a point
of departure and that human
freedom is the ultimate the unique end
to which
human beings ought to destin themselves
so it's a denial of of our own freedom
she also has this interesting analysis
of the term
useful and she paradoxically says that
they give an absolute meaning to the
term useful
why is that paradoxical because if
useful is understood
properly as it is in moral philosophy
useful expedient
helpful any of those sorts of things
it's not absolute
useful is a relational term
useful for this right money
is useful money is useful to buy things
credit cards are useful in the same way
that money is
actually other ways as well they're
useful for the buyer
to get some things that they want
they're useful for the credit card
companies to soak people for a very long
time
by charging high interest rates right
but even that utility
involved in the credit card company
presumably
that's not their their goal in life is
to you know
trap people into credit card debt
and make money off of them they want to
make that money so that they can do
something else with that money
themselves
but if they're the serious person they
could say
wow this is such a great arrangement i
must do everything
to make sure that this happens this
happens in school a lot too
if you think about how people can be
sticklers about assignments and there's
no
real conception of what the assignment
is for the assignment becomes
the end in itself or a certain way of
teaching right
useful it has to be in relation to other
things and she says that
in truth useful has no more meaning if
taken by itself
than the words high low right and left
it designates a relationship and a
compliment
the compliment must be put into question
and as
we'll see later on the whole problem of
action is then raised and then she says
the serious person doesn't put anything
into question
for the military man the army is useful
it's given this word but useful doesn't
mean just useful for something
it means of value for the colonial
administrator the highway
for the serious revolutionary the the
revolution
and she says all of these can become
inhuman idols to which one will not
hesitate to sacrifice
the human being themselves and here she
shifts to the next
point so we talked earlier about a
person becoming a slave
to the the value a person can also
become a tyrant as well
tyrant is somebody who rules arbitrarily
over others
and generally without any reference to
you know
we call ethical norms right so you can
become a tyrant
how she says that um
here we go uh ignoring the value of the
subjectivity
and the freedom of others to such an
extent that sacrificing them to the
thing
this person persuades themselves that
what they sacrifice is nothing
the colonial administrator who has
raised the
highway to the statute stature of an
idol will have no scruple about assuring
its construction at the price of a great
number of lives of the natives
for what value has the life of a native
who is incompetent lazy and clumsy when
it comes to building highways
the object becomes the thing that
matters the most and it could even be
arranged in this sort of way the highway
these silly natives don't realize how
much this highway
is going to radically improve their
lives so if we have to kill a few of
them in the process
in order to make the highway exist for
the benefit of natives in the future
well you know that that's just too bad
and this is tyrannical because who's
deciding this it's the
person who is the serious colonial
administrator
and they they don't respect the freedom
or the value
of other people now what she says is the
dishonesty here
is ignoring the subjectivity of his
choice pretending
that the unconditioned value of the
object is being
asserted through them i am the one who
speaks for the highway i am the one
who speaks for the political cause i am
the one who speaks for what it means to
be genuinely catholic
as opposed to all those fake catholics
over there this this sort of seriousness
can be found in many different modes
and you know that's not to say that
speaking for something automatically
makes you the serious
person or criticizing others within
one's own uh you know universe or group
or domain
it's the way that it's done it's it's
the investment
that's that's taking place and the fact
that one doesn't take responsibility
prime example of this is when a famous
uh
philosopher at a lock conference
is told to me by one of my professors
who was a
very important lock scholar there was a
dispute about what locke
meant in one of his books and he got up
and he slammed his hand down on the
table
and he said that is not my doctrine and
then suddenly he realized what he meant
to say is that is not locke's doctrine
he had so identified himself as like the
defender
of john locke and the proper expositor
of it
against all these other rum dumbs over
here who are making you know frivolous
claims about it
that he lost sight of the fact for a
moment
that he wasn't john locke and he wasn't
the only person to speak for john locke
he might have been at the apex
of his profession and highly regarded
but other people's viewpoints could be
correct now he recognized that the
serious person often doesn't
there is one other uh thing that that
she she talks about
in relation to this
dishonesty and that is like she says in
order to justify the contradictory
absurd and outrageous aspects of this
kind of behavior
the serious man takes refuge in
disputing the serious
but it's the serious of others he
disputes not his own
so it's okay to make fun of other
people's political causes
or you know if you're uh
an anti-vegetarian you're like we should
all eat meat make fun of those silly
vegetarians
right or vegans um but you don't make
fun of your own stuff
as a matter of fact if somebody pokes at
yours that's off limits
right now you've crossed the line but
it's perfectly fine
to tear down and make fun of others
so like she she says the colonial
administrator is not
unaware of the trick of irony he can
test the importance of the happiness the
comfort the very life of the native
but he reveres the highway the economy
the french empire
he reveres himself as a servant of these
divinities
and then she goes on and i don't know if
this is actually verifiably true but
it's a good line almost all serious
people cultivate an expedient
levity right they hide from themselves
the incoherence of what they're they're
doing
in that way and she she also talks about
how again the the
the serious person and the sub man can
share
space within the same person one last
thing from this that i think is kind of
poignant
she talks about as soon as the person
leaves
the domain of where they're at involved
in the serious
they become dull the serious man's life
loses all meaning if he finds himself
cut off from his
ends she says ordinarily he does not put
all his eggs into one basket but if it
happens that a failure or old age
ruins all his justifications unless
there's a conversion
he no longer has any relief except in
flight ruined dishonored
his important personage is now only a
has
been right now there is a num there is
another thing that needs to be said
and this is a qualification that she
makes
some people can be forced into the
universe of the serious
she says certain adults can live in the
universe
of the serious in all honesty who would
those be
those who are denied all instruments of
escape those who are enslaved or who are
mystified
the less economic and social
circumstances
allow an individual to act upon the
world the more this world appears to
them as
given so this is something very
important not everybody
has the same degree of freedom and this
is typically
a product of the societies that we we
live within
as well as you know smaller groups like
say families
a person could be within a family where
because of the
the trauma and abuse that's been going
on in their family they
they wind up being forced into the
serious
but were they in other circumstances um
they they would be able to escape that
you know and she goes on
and she she says that um
this is the is the case of women who
inherit a long tradition of submission
and of those who are called the humble
or we say the little people
right and then she goes on and she says
we have to be a bit careful about this
there is
often laziness and timidity in their
resignation their honesty is not quite
complete
but to the extent that it exists their
freedom remains available it is not
denied
they can know the truth of existence and
raise themselves
to a properly moral life she gives the
example of
ibsen's play a doll's house where
the heroin rebels against the lie of the
serious and so you could say that the
more
the more capacities we have the more
that we're in a position
of you know having access to
to understanding ourselves uh the less
we're restricted by society the more
we're privileged
the more responsibility we have and some
people
uh have so many things going against
them and it may
you know it may have to be understood in
a complex way
i i suspect the more that they have
going against them the more they may be
forced into the serious
and there isn't this dishonesty this
inauthenticity
marking it but it's also still not
a condition that that she wants to
advocate for it's it's
it's problematic for a different reason
so this is the the domain of the serious
person as de bouvoir is sketching it out
for us
you